[موسيقى]
في اعالي جبال الاطلس وبين سفوحها تختبئ
فاجعه اخرى من ضحايا زلزال المغرب استغرق
وصولنا الى قريه نحو اربع ساعات بسبب
الطرق الوعره
هنا جماعه امجدال التي تبعد 20 كيلومترا
فقط عن مركز زلزال الحوز المدمر القريه
الصغيره هذه هدمت بالكامل على رؤوس سكانها
دون سابق انذار ليله وقوع الزلزال منطقه
بسيطه معظم بيوتها مبنيه او مكسوه بالطين
الاحصاءات تشير الى وفاه 45 شخصا واصابه
العشرات في هذه القريه رغم صغر حجمها اما
من نجا فهو تائه دون ماوى
تجولنا في شوارع القريه وشاهدنا حجم
الدمار الكبير الذي اصاب بنيتها التحتيه
المتهلكه اصلا هذه المعالم المدمره هي كل
ما تبقى من بيوتها وذكريات سكانها اما حال
اهلها فهم يفترشون الخيام منذ ايام
التقينا بعدد منهم ووصفوا رحله نزوحهم
التي لم تكن ولن تكون اشد قساوه من ليله
الزلزال
الحمد لله سيدي ربي
ولكن الدار كلشي كلشي يضر في الاخر
كلشي
انما نحمد الله ونشكره على نعمه لانه احنا
عندنا واحد مساله كانتعاونوا اما
ضواويله عبر الدواب وكانوصلوا لهم حتى هما
مثلا
الا انه باقي وحيدا بعد ان توفي جميع
افراد اسرته جراء الزلزال حاول مصطفى
تمالك نفسه والحديث عن ليله الفاجعه
بتفاصيلها
واصطحبنا الى المقبره الجماعيه التي دفن
فيها ضحايا القريه
هذا كل ما تبقى للشاب مصطفى
خوادريه فتيحه مسوده في 2012
والوالده والوالده دفنت اسره مصطفى والدته
والده واخواه الصغيرين الرائحه هنا لا
زالت قويه الجثث لا زالت طريه ولذلك وضع
اهالي القريه بعد الحواجز لمنع الحواجز
نباتيه هي وحاده لمنع الكلاب من الاقتراب
من المقابر هذه ليست مقبره وانما هو سفح
جبل لكنه اضحى بين ليله وضحاها مقبره
جماعيه
وضعت فيها جثث ضحايا قريه
التي قضوا بسبب الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه
منطقه الحوز ليله الجمعه الثامن من سبتمبر